well i don't to tell you this 2020 has
been a tough year for all of us
it's taken a toll on health and finances
and that includes non-profits as well
like opportunity village
which helps adults who are mentally
disabled here in our community
so many fundraisers have been canceled
that includes the magical forest so they
really need our help right now
and we are so excited to team up with
our friends at sunny 106.5 to host a
very sunny christmas
we have the beautiful joanna joining us
this morning hey joanna it's so great to
see you
good morning hi good morning alex thanks
for having me on
oh we're so excited to talk to you you
know we've been getting a little preview
of some of the performers that are part
of this
airing tomorrow afternoon can you talk
to us about some of those
yes i mean to be honest with you alex we
had so many great entertainers
interested in being a part of a very
sunny christmas
we have an amazing lineup wayne newton
debbie gibson darius rucker we've got
little big
town matt franco murray the magician the
las vegas aces are a part of it the
vegas golden knights
uh pif the magic dragon murray the
magician we've got
20 acts packed into an hour for you it's
going to be
amazing i know i'm so excited to see it
all come together
and you know joanna obviously it's been
such a hard year for non-profits
can you talk about why it's so important
to benefit opportunity village right now
absolutely i feel like the community
really rallies around just organizations
in general and
during the pandemic it's been hard for
everybody
opportunity villages main fundraising
happens this time of the year
they've got the great santa run that had
to change they have the magical force
that got completely canceled which is
heartbreaking because that's such
a great tradition in our community and
right now we just need to rally behind
them
support them and with their services and
that's why we put this together so
people can
be entertained and you know what if you
can give a dollar five dollars whatever
you can give during our special tomorrow
would mean
so much to opportunity village no amount
is too small
no and it's going to be such a good
special too you know joanna we've talked
to a lot of performers and magicians i
know you have two
throughout the year about how difficult
it's been they've been getting creative
to try to just stay busy
um and it's so cool to see them now
coming together to just benefit another
great cause
absolutely it's gonna be fun to see
these huge names in the comfort of their
own homes
doing exclusive acts for our special and
our special only
so they are really gonna bring it uh
during a very sunny christmas i mean
they want us to raise
as much money as we can for opportunity
village and we really hope to do that
during this jam-packed hour of
entertainment it's going to be
so amazing i know it and you know uh we
were so bummed not to be able to do this
with you guys
in person in the same room of course
because of covid we're trying to be safe
uh but we're so excited to team up with
you guys and thank you for all of the
beautiful holiday music you guys have
been bringing us
i started listening to it back i think
it was the very beginning of november
thank you for all the joy
we felt like the valley needed more
holiday cheer than ever before this year
so we're like
right after halloween we're like let's
get into the holiday music and people
have been absolutely
loving it so we are so happy to team up
with your
everybody at eight news now you guys
have been fantastic thank you for
partnering with us this has been
so much fun and i can't wait for
tomorrow uh well we are happy to partner
with you guys too thank you so much
joanna you have a great morning
and we will see you alex thank you we'll
see you tomorrow afternoon three o'clock
the show airs right here on channel
eight you can also watch it on christmas
it airs at noon
and 6 30 p.m some really great names as
you see on the bottom of the screen
there
uh we're really excited to bring that to
you all right it is 6 18 this morning
good morning you guys it's starting to
feel a little more like the holidays out
there
yeah sure one of the things that we saw
in addition to the great entertainers
uh perhaps even more important they had
the cookies that you can get from
opportunity village if you need a last
minute holiday gift
think about buying those cookies to
benefit opportunity village
and something for you to give to
somebody right sherry
i think that's a great idea nate and i
don't know how late they'll take the
orders but
i need some gifts and i think those
cookies would really
be the ticket so that's a great idea
plus
just tune in and get in some holiday
spirit holiday fun
alex can't wait for the show and